wie geht es Ihnen als Unternehmer sie
sind ich habe mir das gerade noch mal
erklären lassen nicht nur Metzgermeister
sondern auch fleischsumme jeder dafür
braucht man noch mal eine zusätzliche
Ausbildung taucht dann noch tiefer dann
in die Material ein welches Zeugnis
geben Sie dem Wirtschaftsminister
welches Zeugnis geben Sie der Regierung
für für das Handwerk für Unternehmen wie
ihr es fühlen sie sich da derzeit
abgeholt nein überhaupt nicht also egal
ob es Handwerk oder Industrie ist wenn
man eigentlich alle komplett
vernachlässigt im Moment und da habe ich
immer
brilliert ja immer mit seinen Interviews
das ist ja gigantisch anzuschauen wie es
Bäckerhandwerk runter gemacht hat mit
dem mir sehr verbunden sind und das geht
einfach nicht und diese Strom und
gaspreisdeckel den hätte man braucht
wenn man sie vorher schon mal drum
kümmert hat was passiert oder wo haben
man Strom überhaupt her ja Angebote
Nachfrage ist halt in der Wirtschaft so
ist und wenn ich vorher nicht ich kann
nicht mehr Wohnung kündigen wenn ich
vorher noch habe aber
sinnlos Frankreich haben
ja Frankreich an der Grenze der bei uns
Einnahmen anderen gut Wartung ist ja
Katastrophe habe ich gekriegt oder wir
gehen jetzt direkt in Ihr Thema rein das
direkt Ihre Kamera wir wollen dass Sie
uns einmal mitnehmen in ihren Alltag Ihr
Unternehmen mehr als 80 Jahre alt und
jetzt aber Campus und jetzt stehen sie
eventuell vor dem Aus und das hat
einiges zu tun mit einer Steckdose Ihre
Kamera
ausdrückt wir kämpfen wir kämpfen es gab
schon immer Probleme wie gesagt wir sind
in der dritten Generation da hat der Opa
schon mit Probleme gekämpft der Vater
hat sie doch kämpfen müssen und auch wir
kämpfen uns doch aber was halt im Moment
einfach abgeht es geht über das ganze
Handwerk ähm egal ob Bäcker Metzger
Schreiner alles was Strom intensiv ist
und metzgereibetriebe sind einfach Strom
intensiv wir haben selbst kleinen
Betriebe über 100000 kW verbraucht ja
und ähm 70% der Metzgerei in Deutschland
sind
Kleinstbetriebe also familiär geführte
Betriebe Kleinbetriebe
wir sind nicht für eine
Regulierung vom Staat aber in dem Fall
muss man was machen weil der Staat hat
ja verschlafen bisher also sollte er
jetzt schon irgendwie in die Gänge
kommen wir haben als Stromnachzahlung
gehabt für eine Filiale da haben wir im
Sportmarkt Vertrag gehabt von 30.000
Euro das ist inzwischen wieder gemeldet
worden weil jetzt ist dann das
Sportmarkt wieder runtergegangen wie
Heizöl und und und so weiter alles jetzt
ist es minimale Rückzahlung haben wir
glaube ich sind 800 € oder sowas super
aber das ist das führt zu nichts weil
wie gesagt wir sind energieintensiv wir
Metzger wir haben viele Kühlräume die
Ware muss kühlt werden wir haben in
Deutschland einen hohen Hygienestandard
das sind alles kosten die sind ja auch
noch zum Tragen und jetzt
und jetzt so viel Energie zum
verschwenden also meine Energie um mit
diesem Thema Strom das es gibt andere
Sachen wo wo auch immer erledigen sind
ja und da da fühlen wir uns im Moment
einfach im Stich lassen definitiv
sicherlich alles auch einmal
durchgerechnet vor allem als die 30 000
€ kamen lassen wir uns das einmal so ein
bisschen in die Praxis übersetzen was
würde es bedeuten zum Beispiel für wie
viel müssten sie zum Beispiel in 250
Gramm Steak verkaufen um zu sagen wir
können uns über Wasser halten wenn wir
solche Energiekosten Beispiel
Schweinesteak Rindersteak Rinderfilet
also da ist die die Range ein bisschen
groß gehen wir mal von der
Leberkässemmel aus also
jeder äh wie gesagt es hat zum Glück nur
ein Geschäft getroffen und die anderen
Geschäfte haben fest Verträge gehabt das
mit dem Sportmarkt hat man halt so
gemacht ist ein empfohlen worden von
Energieberater so dann haben wir das mal
gemacht
im Nachhinein hat mir angekriegt muss
geendet hat und umgerechnet die
Habsburger umgerechnet aber ich sage mal
lieber gesammel 5 Euro
um irgendwie sowas weil ich mein Auto
Bäcker für seine Semmeln erhöhte Kosten
ja wenn man da habe kauft seine Brötchen
ja am liebsten im Discounter gesagt und
nicht beim Bäcker weil der kann ja mal
kurz zu sparen für ein paar Monate dass
er im Discounter aber ohne die deutschen
Arbeitsplätze unterstützt das ist
meistens TK-Ware ist wo eben nicht aus
deutschen Handwerker hinten stammt da
hat er auch anscheinend daran gedacht
das ist einfach von vorne bis hinten
für 5 € anbieten glauben Sie die kaufen
noch jemand nein natürlich nicht und es
wurde passieren im Endeffekt ist es so
bei jeder gut wir schaffen die Betrieb
braucht ja
ein bisschen Rückhand wir ähm da können
wir ja auch erzählen davon ja aber es
soll ja okay wartungsschau entstehen
maschinenwartungen Anbauten und so
weiter
sie wollen weitermachen sie wollen dass
es weitergehen meine Mitarbeiter sind
uns wichtig mir mein Bruder ist ja klar
ja weil jetzt geht es natürlich dann da
los mit der mit der lohn-spirale wie es
so schön heißt in der Rezession und
natürlich wollen wir mehr zahlen aber
das geht natürlich nicht wie man das
ganze Geld an unsere Regierung
verschenken was wollen Sie ganz konkret
formulieren Sie mal was Sie jetzt
brauchen was soll die Politik tun was
muss die Regierung tun damit sie so
weitermachen können wie bisher damit
Ihre Mitarbeiter weiterhin guten Lohn
bekommen dass man nicht 5 € für die
Leberkässemmel zahlen muss ganz einfach
die akadem laufen lassen weil wir haben
im Moment überhaupt keine Alternative
wie sollten funktionieren die kann doch
nicht abschalten dann nur Autos
verlangen zum fahren alle und dann
sollen wir ja also das geht ja nicht das
ist wieder das Prinzip der Angebote
Nachfrage
viele Metzger Betriebe haben in bestehen
in letzter Zeit in in Solaranlagen und
haben Sie auch welche haben wir auch
genau Wärme Rückgewinnung wir haben
Wärme ihre Gewinnung im Haus wie die
meisten weil es wäre idiotische Energie
raus zum Blasen die man dann wieder
benutzen kann also aber das ist im
Moment wirklich hier Tropfen auf dem
heißen Stein
e weiter die AKWs müssen weiterlaufen
ganz klare Forderungen
dass sie Brennstoffe brauchen in der
Regel ist es so dass die Brennstoffe
konkret für ein Kraftwerk gemacht werden
übrigens woher die meisten Brennstäbe
kommen übrigens aus Russland da wollen
wir aber keine mehr also insofern ist
das ein schwieriges Thema ich würde bin
ich jetzt bei meinem Thema wäre
mit den AKWs sondern um was es geht da
haben sie einen richtigen Punkt wir
müssen das Angebot an Energie bei uns in
der Bundesrepublik erhöhen und
insbesondere auch ich sage auch viele
Energie so lang mit den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren noch nicht so weit haben
der soll jetzt forciert werden ist
übrigens richtig was dort die Regierung
macht den Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien
zu forcieren aber erst wenn man die hat
muss man was anderes abschalten sonst
wird schwierig und das ist das was wir
da wir haben sozusagen und selber die
Energie
gekilltische
[Gelächter]
ja also man kann ich einerseits sagen da
haben sie ja völlig recht es muss das
Angebot erhöht werden damit die Preise
sind so funktioniert und gleichzeitig
sagen ja die drei Atomkraftwerke die ist
nur noch bis zum nächsten Frühling
weiterlaufen die nutzen uns nein da
müssen die länger laufen da müssen
andere ans Netz da muss man auch
überlegen ob man vielleicht sogar neue
Planet da muss man sich auch mal
überlegen zumindest ich kann es ja nicht
entscheiden natürlich aber sich
überlegen ob man Fracking macht Fracking
Gas aus Amerika beziehen ist gut in
Deutschland nur nachdenken ist das
verstehe ich nicht also wenn man
wirklich sagt alle Energie Kräfte müssen
jetzt an Bord sozusagen damit der
Dampfer Deutschland wieder flott wird
und vielleicht den Gaspreis entkoppeln
weiterbauen so weit es möglich ist
Fracking tabulos diskutieren und dann
sich wirklich auch schauen ob man
gewisse Auflagen sie haben sie teilweise
angesprochen auch mal gehabt die Grünen
haben jetzt angekündigt es soll nächstes
Jahr kommen eine Solaranlagen Pflicht
auf jeden Dach das wird auch wieder
horrente Kosten verursachen warum
steigen auch die Mieten beispielsweise
wegen der Dämmpflicht also
meine Kühlräume nachts nicht so ist es
genau also es wird nach wie vor
kurzem Angst ist im Moment eigentlich
von dem Blackout wo immer geredet wird
man muss immer mehr Leben in Deutschland
und und reden über solche Themen das ist
ja eigentlich ehrlich
die ist auch unzumutbar für Sie für die
Bäcker aber jetzt noch mal zu den
Atomkraftwerken bei den Atomkraftwerken
weil sie sich so einsetzen wir hatten im
Sommer die Situation dass die Hälfte
aller französischen Atomkraftwerke nicht
betrieben werden konnten wissen Sie
warum
niedrig waren inzwischen ja weil wir
haben jetzt die nächste Situation
werden konnten sondern was ist passiert
wir mussten unsere Gaskraftwerke
anschmeißen um Strom zu produzieren um
den tollen Atommüll an Frankreich
Atom sozusagen glaube ich nicht die
Lösung doch wir haben ein Teil der
Lösung sondern du musst nur deine
argumentieren erstmal kommen die die
Atomkraftwerke sind überhaupt nicht mehr
Sicherheit geprüft warum weil immer
investiert worden ist weil schon gesagt
hat mir schalten Sie ab das muss
natürlich alles berücksichtigen den
Vorschlag machen und deshalb heute den
Vorschlag mit den Atomkraftwerken jetzt
für diesen drei Monaten die machen es
gerade nicht fett auch Angesicht werden
die gesamten Energieverbrauch das ist
ein Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein wenn
Sie so wollen wir ja machen dieser ist
ja aber das ist nicht das Problem das
Problem ist dass wir insgesamt viel zu
wenig Energie haben weil wir jetzt
müssen sie doch einen Wirtschaftskrieg
mit den Russen führen in deren Folge
kriegen brauchen
abends nicht mehr abgenommen
das sinnlos ich möchte einmal auch Sie
dazu Fragen sie als Soldat wir haben
also sie werden wir schon über ihre
Auslandseinsätze gesprochen jetzt
sprechen wir gerade über das Thema
Energie wir sehen hier es reicht nicht
es kommen Menschen in Bedrängnis ist es
für sie spürbar spüren Sie die
explodierenden Energiepreise macht sich
das in ihrem Alltag bemerkbar also das
hast du jetzt gerade gesagt hast das
merkt man natürlich im gesamten Freundes
und Bekanntenkreis also alle die
selbstständig sind gucken jetzt aktuell
wie machen wir es und was kommt
vielleicht als nächstes für eine Zahlung
rein und dann muss ich der selbständige
natürlich auch überlegen lohnt sich das
dann überhaupt für mich noch und dann
ist ja die Sache wenn diese
Leistungsträger in Deutschland
wegbrechen die vielleicht sogar noch
Arbeitsplätze bereitstellen dann wird es
vielleicht dunkel in Deutschland und das
ist dann halt eben sehr traurig und die
andere Thematik was was Sie gesagt haben
wir wollen jetzt nichts von Russland
mehr haben
ist natürlich auch so ein
zweischneidiges Schwert also wenn man
natürlich nichts mehr aus Russland haben
will und dann in andere lupenreine
Demokratie geht dann ist das natürlich
eine Sache ja
wo fangen wir an wo hören wir auf und
das finde ich halt eben so ein bisschen
dass
scheinheilige wenn ich es mal so
vorsichtig ausdrücken darf und das macht
mich
wütend traurig und wenn ich die
Geschichten dann höre das ist ja nur
eine Geschichte und es kommt andauernd
solche Sachen und das hört einfach nicht
auf und das zu der persönlichen
Geschichte bei mir kommt es halt noch on
top mit der kleinen Sahne oben drauf und
die Kirche und das ja ist einfach fast
ohne Boden es geht um den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland wenn wir
abwandert unsere Sachen dann merkt es
ist Stuttgart
brauchen wir den strompreisdeckel das
ist wichtig auch Gas Gas das sind die
Bäcker wieder mehr betroffen wir
brauchen mehr Strom aber das sind alles
so Sachen
ja das wäre halt wichtig dass damals